i thought today we could talk about some
spicy industry news guys
so yeah so if you didn't know this a
small
indie you know indie anime site called
kiss anime
recently went out of business business
yeah business
yeah i guess we just wanted to talk
about that talk about piracy
because you know that that always goes
well on the internet twitter has been a
mess
oh my god when is twitter not a mess oh
god i've seen so many garbage tapes
yeah do we want to explain what the kiss
anime even is what a kiss yeah
what is this animal what is a kiss anime
i'll explain it okay
monkey brain here to explain things for
you explain it like i'm five
kiss anime was probably the most
notorious and well-known
anime piracy website for streaming for a
while for all
not not anymore not anymore but i'd say
at least three years ago it was
definitely like
the site yeah it was the time and then
you know as somebody who at one point
used it it definitely became a thing of
oh we're using dot
are younow instead of dot com okay
that's a little confusing
yeah and then and then suddenly you have
to like like dispose of a bomb or
something yeah you're like
pictures yeah the capture got so [ __ ]
complicated
that i was i was like i didn't know how
to navigate it and then it got to a
point where any
any anywhere you click on the website
you got an ad yeah
it was it was like trying to navigate
mindfulness it's like where can i click
i was like
turn into like sulfurics it was a
trigonometry question
you would ask for like cat cat and
bluescape
it had essentially become the second
page of google it was like absurd
at this point it was like a minefield
anyway it was it was definitely the most
notorious
i'd say overall website among the anime
fandom and it recently closed its doors
and people seemed
very upset about that for some reason as
if there isn't like five hundred other
websites that are
one thing that really confused me is
that why are people sad
yeah i guess who's still using kiss
anime in 2020 yeah come on
like i i hate the fact that i
i've just joke tweeted being like rip
kiss anime rip broke weebs and it became
my most popular
it's got like 90 000 likes i'm like what
who is like hashtag can relate it's my
most popular tweet and i hate it
i hate it but like because yeah i i
jokingly said that in the sense of like
yeah who the [ __ ] uses kissanim in 2020
and so many people are like
relate queen yeah
you turn it out it is broke weebs i
don't understand twitter
yeah i know that's horrible people like
i don't know if you guys got this but
like adding me being like you need to
discuss this it's such big community
news i was like why
what do you mean scythe gets shut down
all the time and then another one pops
up like
yeah it's the reason we had like every
single country extension ever
of kiss anime is because they moved to
every [ __ ] country until they
literally have non-left eyes yeah i saw
like i
i saw kiss anime having a dot whatever
in like
in in things that i've never even seen
like i was like are you i'm like
yeah that's russia right that's right
you know okay i i i don't offend
the russian fans of trash taste and we
have a russian dog yeah we have like a
giant rock
right but i'm sorry i feel i feel very
uneasy when i see that dot
ru yeah in my browser i'm like whoa
you know something shady going on if
it's on you love russia though yeah
totally other things though right
not only kiss sam it's like kiss manga
kiss cartoon
cartoon there's a kiss hentai as well i
think yeah i think so
yeah yeah there's actually a kiss hentai
no no yeah i remember somehow i got on
to kiss cartoon and like family guy was
like the most popular and i just sat
there for a second i'm like
people are pirating family guy like
you know youtube exists the episode
isn't
available everywhere do you remember
that phase where they were just like
there was a streaming phase where
family guy episodes would just be like
streamed on youtube yeah and it would
just be like 24-hour family guys stream
24 hours simpsons stream front page of
[ __ ] youtube as well
not official is it no no no no no no
it's not official and yet like every
time i'd open
youtube they'd just be like 24 hours a
24 7
stream of the cleveland show i'm like
and there was like
700 000 people watching this stream i
was just like
what uh yeah but yeah it's the same
thing that happened with like hentai
haven right when hentai haven got shut
down
people are like oh yeah where are we
going to watch our hentai now i'm like i
don't know
google that [ __ ] there's literally 700
websites for i felt so out of the loop
because i never used hentai haven and
when everyone was losing their [ __ ] i
was like but why don't you just use like
the website i'm using why don't you just
use every other website
yeah but yeah question to you melin
because you actually work in the
industry
so what is your opinion on kiss anime
and it's shutting down as a whole
from like from like someone on the other
side of the wall
yeah someone someone who like works with
you know the the copyright oh really i
work in like the anime side i work more
on like the manga
occasionally like we'll do something
with the anime so i can't really speak
for the anime industry
with like most of the discussion on
twitter and like most of the discussion
on our side a lot of it is just
speculation we don't actually know
how much piracy affects the industry you
know what i mean i don't think
i think it can be argued there's nothing
like concrete stats right there isn't
like because i don't think any of these
piracy sites are making that [ __ ] public
of like how much money they're actually
because they're making a disgusting
amount on all those kinds of yes
i mean at one point kiss anime was like
one of the top 100 visited websites
on the internet which is [ __ ] insane
that's crazy like imagine how much money
they were making just from ad revenue of
being like the top
probably uh worth it to keep evading you
know
yeah yeah what i mean exactly i mean
they they made a disgusting amount of
money that they
really shouldn't have been making yeah
because because don't a lot of the
because you know obviously when you
watch something pirated it's not using a
standard youtube
player or like a normal it's using one
of those really sketchy third-party
websites that host like anything
i'm pretty sure those websites as well a
lot of the ones they were using would
pay you
to host files right right like video
files because they wanted that player to
become more
like universal so a lot of these were
also kiss anime at the time
again i'm not sure but from what i
understood they were getting ad revenue
like a lot of it
i imagine because you know you go on
that website and you've got like what 10
[ __ ] ads caught asian
data singles in your area
always [ __ ] lois from family guy
being rammed and it's like i'm just
trying to watch
anime like what is this no and that'd be
always like these shitty
hentai games that would be yeah so it
would be like advertising i think one
time i was watching
something and just this ad with like
[ __ ] wars
or a game called that and i'm just like
are you is this for real
is this for real right now i think
that's a real game because that's just
sticking out my mind
i want to play [ __ ] wars just from the
[ __ ] name i love i love run to go
don't you accidentally like click on
those ads sometimes and then once you
click it's like boom
boom boom boom boom all these pop-up
windows yeah it's like sex-free
now in your area like that like it's but
yeah so they were getting like double
dipping ad revenue they were getting
paid to host the files and they were
sorry i leaned back i always [ __ ] do
that yeah
stop going yes so okay so they were
getting like double ad
basically right so and and then you know
people on twitter which i i disagree
with i think you can
uh say okay there is a need for piracy
in some extent right but then there's
people who like boohoo kiss anime
man it's just like they're they're doing
the real hard work it's like are you
kidding me
it's probably like four dudes racking in
millions bro what are you feeling sorry
for them what the [ __ ]
so wait so i didn't see like the full
story of like how they got shut down
i mean i i i assume they just got shut
down by some dmca clients right
like but see because they've they've had
their thing shut down
several times right yeah they went from
like his anime dot com to like dot net
to like dot r u eventually right yeah
and then and when that happened there
was also like
not as obviously not as big because i
don't think there were articles about it
but people were definitely making a fuss
of like oh no kiss anime is down and
then two weeks later they're back with
this
url so that's what i just assumed when i
saw that article i was like oh they'll
be back like
i think it's the first time they've put
in like a like a message saying like
yeah it's over
yeah like right discord right i think so
yeah
they had a discord who the [ __ ] is in
the kiss anime discord
unique it was like i love kiss anime so
much i'm going to
join the discourse yeah there's there's
always that argument that people present
where it's like uh what is it gabe
newell said like piracy as a service
problem or something
i think it's gone way past yeah i think
so because the
piracy as a service problem argument
always gets brought up and it's just
like
it's a different it's a different
situation with the anime industry
so yeah games is a really different
thing like you ever tried to pirate a
game like that [ __ ] is like
annoying yeah exactly like straight up
just annoying but like one thing i find
unique to anime piracy right
and and even hentai to the same extent
as well
is that in no one in no other industry
do i see a pirate service
get like the branding power that it does
in anime
it's true like you think okay if you
want to pirate a movie or if you want to
pirate a game where where'd you go
where'd you go for that you probably go
to google right but there's no like
oh yes there's kiss gaming i go to kiss
gaming every day
i would dive kiss game are you part of
the kiss gaming discord downloaded [ __ ]
wars